yeah welcome to this video Dec about 10
seconds okay I'm playing soccer mum
slacker among from from Switzerland
isn't this position where I can play
Quidditch for sometimes you can play the
strange moves huh so just a simple
simple covering of this ok yeah i
understand it so it's probably just the
gable white welcome maybe i can can put
my queen it to some use 94
okay I move like 94 is probably really
bad I should I should maybe have a look
at the edge to bond aha so one he's are
you really leaving I'm threatening
something I don't don't believe that
okay maybe I can play if I can i play
some work he move like g5 trying to do
to make any sense of this come on it
looks it looks really strange yeah yep
but now i can i can really enter here
not that it's necessarily brilliant but
at least i can get near the king okay
how to how to proceed here g4 Bishop g2
words not really helping d 5 is
completely completely stranger
does he threaten to take here maybe
there's also before yeah at the end you
need to recognize if you play all these
strange rules you probably have a
strange position it's not a
revolutionary thing to recognize okay
let's at least prevent before for the
moment
hmm didn't expect that you're taking us
probably not helping yeah maybe study
five straight as it looks you're taking
on d6 it's not not the end of the world
but it's looking it's looking really
weird yeah it's not the end of the world
but close to it I can play 9 p-5 now wow
what the heck am I playing here mmm ah
this looks really ugly that just might
be five but ok it's a probably a
probably white can play an almost
enemies Wow whatever you do and chest
don't repeat this this set up yeah I
need to play this brilliant news just to
cover d6 you can you can take on d6 and
play 97 winning in exchange but it's
probably am probably not enough for this
position it's perfectly perfectly good I
mean it's not not criticizing it um it
just looks like there might be something
oops I can just get my queen you just
can't gave me the Queen yeah Wow
completely busted I mean they can just
just play anything what the heck yeah I
mean I'm not sure Queen a choice maybe
still it's a bit strange but not not
entirely entirely bad so somewhere
around here maybe yeah g5 is just it's
just completely insane what the heck did
i do them and even spent 30 seconds on
this nonsense probably I should I should
just take ya g fiber so now i need to
get my my head examined ed 5 is probably
still ok some something like that I know
if maybe here yeah I don't know
everything's better than what I plate
alright so whatever you do never ever
play like that what it is this game
thanks anyway